darling I think I'm now officially the  fastest sideways and I am front about  knowing you don't need those  I am your marrow fight darling no I'm  looking for Nobu this week you don't  know this and I don't know this but Kate  Moss is changing out the Cape a study by  Maryland's biggest fashion event of the  year hi Johnny  oh god I can't believe you're still  alive police continue to search the  times after you have killed Kate Moss  Courtney it's the best thing I've ever  had from stomach  we've gotta get away we've got to go now  when this is actually over yeah really  free its arrival to go back for the  boots that I just saw on West with  window  everyone's a criminal the estate play  yachts what is this some kind of late  life lesbo party where are the men  Cheers  don't British Airways  I'm being Trollied on Twitter a woman  talk now is a pariah do you know what a  pariah is yeah it's a fish  on the rocks in a meeting recently